I have the personality that babies don't
like usually hi my name is Grace help me
do not know now you know your life is
different now look who's here hello this
is glozell yeah okay is you good cuz I
wanted up was I supposed to say that
softer like oh you're great okay okay so
we just over on clothes else channel
made some really festive holiday
sweaters when you're done make sure you
go watch that video because we have a
future in fashion design you need to
take it on role and for my channel I
thought that we would make festive
holiday bath bombs what have you ever
made a bath bomb before no it sounds
pretty dangerous I've never made one
either so this is gonna beat first okay
so we have to read this book no no no no
no no exit ome gloves and something like
a like a ping on my face we debrief and
stuff like we'll find out I mean oh here
we go it's very easy apparently Diane
got some directions for us off of
Pinterest so we have all of the
accoutrements I know you was bilateral
cross over us I thought to make these
extra special holiday oriented bath
bombs we've all these little trinkets
that we can put inside the bath bomb so
this should be easy
so think but we'll find out so we got to
put all the dry ingredients in a ball so
first one is whoa I knew one of these
this one bit the cons or whatever that
new mute that new money called bits cons
it's five euros so when you travel to
Europe you can use it provocative you
can just go to a exchange right uh-huh
I'll still have to go to Europe alright
so first thing we need a cup of baking
soda all right the winner gonna be now
for you I'm just eyeballing okay now I
do
okay now I need a half cup of citric
acid I never did a sit before you're
doing acid today I don't think you're
supposed to do that let's see this after
use like from like oranges no no no no
no done it's a sprouting agent so Wow
goes out takes a break okay okay so then
we need a half cup of Epsom salt put
that in your mouth yeah I need it for
some mineral yep it's an asset in the
dough in the bowl I think I put a hole
in my bag I was no joke you look
beautiful
we need a half cup of Epsom salt that's
gonna guess he's going there perfect
okay now we whisk these - yeah I'll just
you know what girl I was thinking this
great minds I think apart I mean that's
close enough you should have a cooking
show I think you'd be perfect I want to
have a cooking show called
I can't cook okay would you come on my
now cooking show I absolutely would but
you would have to bring the food because
I don't cook oh that's how it works
oh it's a glitch now we put three
teaspoons of olive oil and then I put in
essential oil in it you went this one
this one is the good night one all Carl
good night my natural I know her no good
night tree no good night plant oh my
gosh I feel air going through my teeth
like I might have done this things are
supposed to add the wet ingredients
the dry ingredients one teaspoon at a
time but that's not how this is going
my teeth are very cool like I feel the
air blowing through them like you know
when you have a pip man just look it out
and you just hello ho that's what
happened and I can't feel the top layer
of my tongue
you didn't blow my esophagus all right
anything else in there all right so now
what did I do
now you mix it and you can put colors in
it if you want I'm gonna use hmm and
then you mix it and you put them in
these are the molds but then we're gonna
make them holiday themed I putting gifts
inside them for people here I'm mixing
mine and then put a little elf inside
you want to have everything in your mind
for Oh like I'm like for real and maybe
more olive oil that you can put in your
mouth but that mm-hmm okay then you pack
them did you swallow well I just want
you to know that my teeth oh oh this is
good
that looks great but this I put a bath
bomb inside of a backbone operas family
so it just fix oh we gonna freeze them
no they just dry we can sell on ec o s
it it sound like one of my achieve name
your mama
that's it Abbi oh my gosh it burns don't
do that
don't put it in your mouth you should
have a serious cousin Kenneth on my
mouth or not oh so this is where you get
paid the big bucks because it's like
your mind be going all the time I just
like regular earth person and you just
be honey wool goodness gracious gracious
Chanel so now I'm I don't so you're done
I just let it dry you let it dry up or I
don't know how long it dries very
quickly and then you can take the molds
off and then you have a bath but if I
don't use these green skin extent oh yes
you can
I'm gonna see if this first one I did
dried already mmm it's a little sticky
oh my gosh let's go and you would never
know there's a treasure inside and this
wasn't that hard to make but I do want
to tell you that for some reason my
mouth is on fire don't put in your mouth
I think that's the major takeaway here
if you're making bathrooms for the
holidays is don't put the ingredients in
your mouth those are the burns and I
think that a tooth is melted Oh
oh my gosh yours is like a little
ornament yeah but it might fall apart
that's okay and then Diane bought this
the if you drop it is this compete this
is also a learning process that you
don't have to follow the directions to
get a successful product I'm so proud of
you right now
thank you can you open yours and see if
it's dry oh that looks gorgeous like
operations
oh so beautiful here we go oh you have a
treasure trove yes but you said I can
have it you can have it okay and you can
have a great time watching the video we
need a Virgo those channels yes please
subscribe Clinton like to miss Grace and
all the channels all the Instagram
snapchat I don't know that is the
inbound Patrice the ghost don't mind
everybody you know make sure you scribe
to hook us she's really cool and I get
keep you can keep whatever you would
like make sure you go check out
closeouts channel and follow her across
all social media because she's up to
shenanigans
you are amazing I can't believe this we
made up I mean you I have a feeling
could probably do a better job at home
so good luck to you and thank you goes
out for just a real fun time I want to
say like this is like I'm Snoop Dogg and
you're like Martha Stewart I just want
to put that out there because it's a
fair assessment this was a beautiful
moment I don't know okay